All right. Hey there. As always, a warm
welcome and a thank you for being here,
especially if this is your first time
with us, Adventist or otherwise.
So, despite all of the uh prophecy
wizards in internet land predicting that
today, April 8, 2024,
with the eclipse
being some major prophetic event,
all sorts of them that I heard, we are
still here.
Not just here, but I'm in Nashville,
which is where it was supposed to be a
big epicenter of a lot of this, but here
we are. And as you can see,
our good old friend is back and making
an appearance.
I brought my uh tinfoil hat for the
evening. Hopefully, you did, too. If I
happen to uh get beamed up during the
stream, hopefully it will protect my
brain from total annihilation.
We will save that for a moment later.
But the million-dollar question,
will all of those false prophets repent
and step down?
Doubtful. They never do. But still the
million-dollar question nonetheless.
Such as this individual for example that
we got a comment from. I left their
grammar as is. By the way,
this person commented today and said,
"Should we be surprised Miles is tight
lipped about Ellen White's Nashville
prophecy?
Not a word from him. Does he fear it
being fulfilled?
He is from Nashville, right? Perhaps
he's waiting to see if it will be
fulfilled. If not fulfilled, he's all
ready to jump in boots and all to scoff
and mock. Correct, Miles.
Miles, how's about scoffing and mocking
before we find out whether her Nashville
prophecy will be fulfilled? Having
doubts?
Ah, yes.
If you all haven't seen, lots of SDAs
were claiming Ellen White's uh Nashville
prophecy was going to lead to the city
being smoked with a fireball today.
And I was uh apparently terrified to
mention anything about it, except uh
here we are. And had this individual
bothered to look before commenting, this
stream has been scheduled for a couple
weeks now. Uh and no, I haven't been uh
tight lipped on this silly prediction.
I've actually been very vocal in the
former Adventist Facebook group where
I've noted how SDA prophecy hunters are
some of the most vocal yet ignorant SDAs
that never learn and unfortunately make
all Adventists look like crackpots even
though they are not. But yeah, here I am
really shaking in my boots, utterly
terrified. In fact, I better be careful
because uh with my tin foil hat on, I'm
shaking so much I might uh conduct
electricity.
So, I also love how it's uh we will see
if Ellen White's Nashville prophecy
comes to pass
because that's how prophecy works
apparently, right? It's this nebulous,
imprecise uh how convenient. Well,
friend, it's still April 8th, so
consider this before we see if you're uh
mesmerist actually got things right for
a change. Don't go scrubbing your
comment now either, friend. But it isn't
all
fringe fanatics online, by the way.
Tonight, we're going to be looking at a
video in a series of videos put out by
Amazing Discoveries, Amazing Fiction.
Uh, a notorious SDA conspiracy outlet
known for all sorts of wacky and
erroneous information. It's headed up by
chief conspirator Walter Ve. Uh, you'll
probably remember him from Total
Onslaught, which aged like a fine milk.
To no surprise, they hopped on the April
8 wave and tried to use it as an
opportunity to not only farm clicks, but
weasel in Ellen White prophecies.
Shocker.
We usually like to aim for a higher
hanging fruit than this at Answering
Adventism. However, I found this
particularly necessary for the sake of
the poor souls out there that are hooked
up to the drip feed of this stuff and
find themselves constantly bamboozled
and hued, suckered into this, being
strung along by fake prophecy merchants
like this that are praying upon your
clicks in the name of being watchmen.
Sadly, there is a huge market of people
out there that lap this type of stuff
up, which creates a supply and demand
for this sort of thing, which is why
it's beneficial to examine it, show why
it's built on falsities, and it presies
upon people's innate attraction, or some
people's, I should say, to fear and
feeling like they have some special
insight into the future. This is by no
means distinct to Adventists. Um, I saw
all the standard prophecy people out
there saying all the same stuff. Uh,
some of those faces we're actually going
to see tonight in the piece of content
that we will be responding to leading up
to the eclipse that took place today.
Amazing Discoveries put out a series of
videos titled Urgent April 8 and the
coming judgments Nashville destroyed.
It kind of sounded like uh one of the
characters from Veggie Tales there.
But we're going to be looking at part
one, which was their best performing
video in at least a month, which
naturally led them to doing out multi uh
like at least two more parts and then
another follow-up part that wasn't
necessarily a part of it to farm as many
clicks as they possibly could before
April 8th. So, before it gets too far in
the rearview mirror and they try to
memoryhole it and move along, I wanted
to examine some of the uh claims and
tactics that are used every single time
there's something like this for places
like Amazing Discoveries to latch on to.
Uh along the way, we will also examine
uh some SDA history where similar things
were done in the past, which provides us
with uh some of the support pieces in
why stuff like this is so rampant within
Adventism and why so many Adventists
have a bent toward consuming this stuff.
But before hopping into it, if you like
what we're doing here, you can support
us by becoming a channel member. For the
price of about a cup of coffee a month,
you can not only help us reach more
Seventh Day Adventists, but will gain
access to our growing library of
membersonly content, including uh access
to come engage in our membersonly live
streams where we work through any
questions that you might have and do
some more hands-on type engagement. Next
one of those will be next week. If this
is something of interest, click that
little join button down below this
video. You can also use the link in the
description box or visit our channel
homepage where you will find the same
one. Your support guys really does make
a huge difference and this work would
not be possible without you. With that
said, let's hop into it, shall we? Seen
what's happening in the news right now?
Well, Mackenzie, I tell you what, I've
gotten a lot of emails and text messages
about this issue. This is really hitting
home. We're going to show you a couple
clips right now. The countdown is on to
a once-in-a-lifetime total eclipse.
Total solar eclipse. Total solar eclipse
on April 8th. On Monday, April 8th, this
could be one of the biggest events of
the decade. On April 8th, there is a
solar eclipse that is coming to the
United States of America. This is an
experience beyond all experiences. You
can't prepare yourself properly for what
this is like. This is a little bit
different. Why is that? because it goes
over seven cities in the United States
that have the same name. What is it? It
is the name Nineveh. Are you kidding me?
No, I'm not kidding you, friends.
Okay, so this is really interesting. And
I want to welcome Don here. He's joining
me for this set of presentations because
he has some very firsthand experience
with some of the things that we're going
to be covering in these couple episodes.
Thanks for having me, McKenzie. Thank
you. So, what is this talking about
here? This April 8.
Well, I think that what we should look
at is what the Bible has to say and why
there's so much excitement about this.
Uh, the Bible does mention that the
things in the heavens are to be used for
signs. Okay. So, just like Don said,
we're going to show you this from
Genesis 1 verse14.
And, uh, Don, could you read this for us
and maybe give us a little insight here?
Absolutely. And God said, "Let there be
lights in the firmament of heaven to
divide the day from the night, and let
them be for signs and for seasons and
for days and for years."
So we see here that the Bible does say
that these things in the sky, sun, moon,
and stars and whatever other objects
might appear are to be used for signs.
And I guess the question that we have to
ask is, is this eclipse that's coming on
April 8th a sign? And if it is, what
does it mean?
Yeah. No, it isn't. Um, I noticed Troy
Brewer was in their clip there. Somebody
at Amazing Discoveries went through,
they had somebody go through and find
all the clips of all these quacks on
YouTube and make a compilation video
with this real ominous music in the
background. Here we are, April 8th, end
of the day. I guess I could be speaking
too soon. We've still got, at least on
central time, we've still got about uh
four and a half hours left. So, maybe
I'm speaking out of turn here. But no,
it meant nothing.
Now, they're going to utilize every
single proof text that all the other
YouTube prophecy charlatans in this
space utilize to try and capitalize on
the current newspaper headline that no
one will remember even in five years
from now. Um the difference is they're
trying to do so by infusing SDA talking
points into the mix. Um as you will see
momentarily. But like I said, as a
Nashville resident, no, the city was not
destroyed and nothing happened. In part
two, they went on to uh and maybe we'll
respond to that in a couple weeks. Um
and see what they went on to say because
they tried to wet your appetite with
this one to make sure you came back for
part two where they talk about a
fireball coming and destroying the city.
Um but no, the city wasn't destroyed.
Nothing happened and Nashville is not
Nineveh. But they started with a
cliffhanger question followed by that
dramatic music playing over snippets of
cliffh clips carefully chosen and edited
together to set the stage for uh
standard newspaper SDA theology which is
basically the standard MO amazing
discoveries. They've been putting out
stuff like this for years. Like I said,
you might recall Walter V's total
onslaught in the uh 2010s. Same exact
thing as what's going on here a decade
later. That is the blueprint that they
now follow. just plugging in whatever
new headline they can. Don, no. Genesis
114 doesn't have anything to do with
Nashville being destroyed on April 8,
2024 because of an eclipse. What we got
here was what is it folks? Word
association fallacy. Seeing the word
sign used of the sun and the moon and
then extrapolating out of that foreign
ideas that the author did not have in
mind. We're really supposed to believe
that what Genesis means, what Moses
meant to com communicate in Genesis, uh,
is that the sun and the moon were placed
in the sky as signs that they're there
for you to to be looking for lunar and
solar eclipses to then try and make all
sorts of silly prophetic extrapolations
to the end of the world. Uh, no. But
notice folks what Albert Barnes says in
his uh, Genesis commentary. Now, we
could look at others as this is not
unique to him, but he just very
succinctly and easily expounds upon the
Hebrew. So specifically on the phrase
for signs and for seasons and for days
and years, he writes,
"While the first day refers only to the
day and its two-fold division, the
fourth refers to signs, seasons, days,
and years. These lights are for signs.
They are to serve as the great natural
uh chronometer of man having its three
units the day, the month and the year
and marking the divisions of time not
only for agricultural and social
purposes but also for meeting out the
eras of human history and the cycles of
natural science. They are signs of place
as well as of time. topometers, if we
may use the term. By them, the mariner
has learned to mark the latitude and
longitude of his ship and the astronomer
to determine with any assignable degree
of precision the place as well as the
time of the planetary orbs of heaven.
The seasons are the natural seasons of
the year and the set times for civil and
sacred purposes which man has attached
to special days and years in the
revolution of time. Close quote.
So by signs, Genesis means markers for
things such as seasons, days, months,
etc., not signs for you to look at and
try and glean all sorts of prophetic
insight into. Nothing in the text
suggests that's what Moses has in view
in Genesis. Very good question. Um, you
know, we have this from Jesus in Luke
21:25-36.
And I'm just going to read the
highlighted portions. If anybody wants
to read the full context, they're
welcome to. But it says, "And there
shall be signs in the sun and in the
moon and in the stars. And for looking
after those things which are coming on
the earth, for the powers of heaven
shall be shaken." So, we're talking
about the current events, right? Yes.
connected to these signs in the sun,
moon, and stars.
And when these things begin to come to
pass, then look up and lift up your
heads for your redemption drawth nigh.
Don, is this saying that when we start
seeing signs in the heavens that Jesus
coming is soon? It does, McKenzie. And
you know, these signs have been going on
for quite a while. And I think we're
going to talk about some of those signs
that have already transpired. And then
we have to look very carefully at this
eclipse and see you know what it means
and is it part of prophecy. Very good
questions. So this says continuing in
Luke 21 and take heed to yourselves lest
at any time your hearts be overcharged
with surfing and drunkenness and cares
of this life and so that day come upon
you unawares. So we have this admonition
that when we see these signs, this is
supposed to awaken us, right? It's
supposed to be like a warning to us. It
is. And we can look at what's going on
in the world today and especially in
North America and we can see that really
it's all about the cares of this life
and having a good time. That's what it
seems like.
All right. So we got the appeal to Luke
21:25-36.
Again, all the prophecy heads in this
space, not just Adventists, they all
appealed to this and they all said the
same thing. This is supposed to justify
their uh vague speculations about this
particular eclipse because it mentions
signs in the sun, moon, and stars, that
means anytime there's something
happening in the sky, it proves the
second coming is about to happen. This
is also where the word association
fallacy is coming from. Again, just
because Genesis 1 mentions the sun and
the moon and signs and then Jesus here
mentions signs in the sun, moon, and
stars doesn't mean contextually the same
thing is in focus. Genesis isn't talking
about a a prophecy or apocalyptic
events. But again, these are the same
proof texts that all these prophecy
charlatans were using and weren't
appealing to the same thing that Dawn
and McKenzie are appealing to. Like I
said, they showed Troy Brewer. Folks, go
look at Troy Brewer's track record. I
mean, my goodness, man. And I know that
they were just using him in their like
montage to set the stage and whatnot,
but that's the type of people who are
doing uh just an amazing exesus of the
text, let me tell you. But let's roll
with this hypothesis, okay? That Jesus's
words in Luke 21 can be connected to the
eclipse from April 8. Notice what NASA
and scientific Americans say regarding
solar eclipses in the 20th century
alone.
Quote,
"On April 8th, a total solar eclipse
will cross 15 US states from Texas to
Maine. The display is unusual enough
that hotels are booking up along the
path and thousands of people plan to
travel to see it.
But just how rare are solar eclipses?"
In the 20th century, 228
were recorded somewhere on Earth, of
which 71 were total solar eclipses. If
the sun and moon don't perfectly align,
you'll see a partial eclipse. On
average, a total solar eclipse is
visible somewhere on the planet every 1
and a half years.
Ah,
so in the 20th century alone,
solar eclipses. Why are you guys picking
this one, Don? Oh, right. That's right.
because oh, there was an opportunity to
farm a bunch of clicks
and then segue into what we're about to
see. But this idea that every time
there's an anomalous one that proves
it's something special and the Bible's
telling us to be uh examining them as
some sort of prophetic scavenger hunt is
not only foreign to the Bible, but it's
silly. And all this did was made the
Christian church, regardless of if if
the world understands SDAs are Christian
or they aren't Christian or Troy Brewer
is a Christian or not, it doesn't
matter. It's a scourge on the body of
Christ. It makes Christians look stupid.
It's an easy lowhanging fruit for them
to then dunk on the Christian faith,
making them making a mockery of the
faith because you have these types who
are telling people that every time
something happens in the sky, it's some
sort of prophetic whatever.
Because this is what happens. Nothing
actually happens, but these sorts of
outlets capitalize on the buzz to try to
make some biblical twist out of it.
Notice Jesus's words to the present
audience in Luke 21, folks.
This is the Achilles heel for Adventism.
I bring this up constantly. Everything
in scripture for Adventism is read
anacronistically,
meaning they read it from their present
vantage point and read back into the
text from where they presently are. Yet
Ted Wilson tells us the only approved
hermeneutic of the SDA church is the
historical grammatical method. Folks,
look into the historical grammatical
method. We're going to be doing a series
of videos on that um eventually breaking
down what that actually is because
that's just lip service. They're just
saying that because the historical
grammatical method involves well history
and the grammar of the text. You first
have to go to the original audience it
was written to and the grammar and
understand how it would have applied to
them. Then you make present- day
application after looking at the grammar
and the original audience. Now,
typically what the SDA church tries to
do in this area is just say, "Oh, double
fulfillment. Everything's a double
fulfillment." Just well, to the
immediate context it meant this, but to
us it means this. We'll see a couple of
those in in a moment. But things are
read into the text from their current
vantage point, 2,000 years removed.
I understand Mackenzie and this guy
aren't Adventist pastors, but it's just
another example of how the SDA church
doesn't actually hold to the HGM, nor do
Adventists within the movement really
understand it. Because Jesus was
speaking to the original audience in
Luke 21. And in verse 28, he tells them,
well, let's look for well, no, no, no.
In verse 28, he told them, when these
things come to pass, look up, lift up
your heads, and so on. That's what
McKenzie and and Dawn are appealing to.
There have been all sorts of celestial
events since Jesus spoke these words.
Thousands, potentially hundreds of
thousands. But the SDA church
arbitrarily arbitrarily labels 1844 as
the start of the end times despite
biblical writers speaking about their
day as the last days and end times which
is uh actually the entire period from
the ascension to the second coming. We
will see how the SDA misunderstanding of
the end times leads to faulty
assumptions in a moment. But when
McKenzie asked, "Is this saying that
when we see signs in the heavens, that
means Jesus is coming soon?" Again, 228
solar eclipses in the 20th century
alone, thousands of them since Jesus
said those words. It's not even
including all the meteor showers and
other celestial events. So, the idea
that Jesus was telling people to do what
these gents are doing is a twisting of
the text and it does not sound
hermeneutics. But look at what McKenzie
skipped over,
which is the forerunner of Jesus's words
in 25 through36.
Same paricopy, folks. Same message that
Jesus is preaching.
But when you see Jerusalem surrounded by
armies,
then know that its desolation has come
near.
Then let those who are in Judea flee to
the mountains, and let those who are
inside the city, Jerusalem, depart,
and let not those who are out in the
country enter it.
For these are days of vengeance, to
fulfill all that is written.
Alas, for women who are pregnant, and
those who are nursing, infants in those
days. For there will be great distress
upon the earth, and wrath against this
people. They will fall by the edge of
the sword and be led captive among all
nations and Jerusalem will be trampled
underfoot by the Gentiles until the time
of the Gentiles are fulfilled. Thus, the
reading of God's holy word. Ah right.
Jesus was foretelling of the destruction
of the temple in AD70. Jerusalem was
indeed trampled underfoot by the
Gentiles and the times of the Gentiles
was indeed fulfilled. I just had a guy
this past week who is a former Adventist
who's now an atheist that tried to say
Jesus is a false prophet. And this is
where he pointed to. I said, 'N no, he's
only a false prophet if you interpret
the way the SD the SDA church interprets
it. And not just them to be totally
fair. But no, it's because you're
reading into it that Jesus is talking
about something he's not talking about
because it did happen just like Jesus
said it would happen. The destruction of
the temple in AD70 was Jesus coming back
in judgment on covenant-breaking Israel
that crucified him. This was foretold in
the Old Testament, not just the New. The
parallel of this is in Matthew 24, which
the SDA church loves.
And the destruction of the temple
symbolized the breaking down of the
barrier between Jew and Gentile. It's
immediately after foretelling about the
Roman Jewish wars that did indeed
surround Jerusalem and the destruction
of the temple that Jesus says there will
be signs in the sun, moon and stars
regarding this people fainting for fear
etc. This is common language that Jesus
is utilizing from the Old Testament such
as uh Ezekiel and Isaiah which talk of
celestial events in the context of
judgment
such as the stars falling from heaven.
But Adventist hermeneutics take this to
be hyperliteral. Everything's
hyperliteral,
but only arbitrarily. So Jesus doesn't
have a literal sword coming out of his
mouth in Revelation. And you'll ask why.
Well, it's obviously not. Oh, okay.
Right. Because it's arbitrary for you.
The stars are literally all going to
crash in on the Earth and result in an
implosion apparently, which is literally
what would happen if the stars were to
literally fall to the Earth.
They're actually going to speak on this
in a bit as Don Frost mentioned, but the
point being to ignore the immediate
context and extrapolate out some
application of this to April 8, 2024
being a sign that Jesus is coming is
around the corner is a bit of a stretch.
It doesn't mean there can't be a double
fulfillment that it referred to 70 AD,
which could be a picture of a greater
cataclysmic event off in the future. But
this is being cited to cherrypick April
8th and make a piece of clickbait.
That's a fact. That is what's going on
here. It's very clear that this was
scripted out, etc. And I get it. I make
content as well. But it's easy to spot
grift like this when you're trying to
ride a wave. And that's what they're
doing here. Jesus could come tomorrow or
10,000 years from now. Theorizing about
all this and making mince meat out of
the Bible to do so is not necessary. And
like I said, it makes Christians look
ridiculous.
I can't tell you how many people I've
talked to that mock the Christian faith
because of lunacy stuff like this that
they grew up in. Not just Adventists,
again, folks, so I'm not just picking on
them. People need to stop doing this
stuff. It makes a mockery of the
Christian faith. And Adventists
obviously hear this and think, "Oh, so
you're saying prophecy doesn't matter?"
I didn't say that. I said, ' Stop
picking on every little thing here and
there to make these stupid claims like
the city of Nashville is Nineveh and
it's going to get hit with a fireball.
No, you need hit upside the head with a
fireball. Knock some sense into you.
Hopefully, you don't need to read into
every single event that's going on that
it's some apocalyptic event. Get busy
for the kingdom. This doesn't do
anything for the kingdom of God. SDAs
think that this sort of stuff, it just
like, well, that's what's going to have
people prepared. I I know all sorts of
dispensational type people there that
same way. It's like, okay, you you've
told me this information now. Now what?
How am I prepared? Great. You shared
this information. It doesn't do
anything. Get busy. Get busy. Disciple
your family, start a family, have kids,
grow the kingdom of God by way of having
children, taking the gospel out into the
culture and the world, influencing the
culture for the kingdom by the way you
live your lifestyle, etc. not just
buying into every little thing that
comes down the pike thinking you have
some special insight when you just look
like a goofball afterward. Don't do
that. What happens is people get sucked
into this stuff and totally distracted.
Nothing happens and then they hop on to
the next one to keep getting their fix
of adrenaline like they're on to
something and the cycle just repeats.
And platforms like an amazing
discoveries supply the demand for this
sort of stuff. But this guy Don Frost,
he he mentioned the cares of this life
running rampant in North America. Again,
Don, this is not new. How is this tied
to April 8? I mean, sir, hedonism has
been a problem in the in the part of the
fallen condition for centuries.
But Adventist theology again writes
North America, specifically the United
States, you know, that lamblike beast
into the book of Revelation into Bible
prophecy. So the idea of America
decaying and falling is basically the
equivalent of the world ending. It is a
very American centric worldview that
tends to see America as the center of
existence. And if America falls, well,
the whole thing's going to fall. What
are people saying in regard to this
eclipse?
Well, people are saying that something
of a magnitude of judgment is going to
take place. See, traditionally eclipses
and um comets and these kinds of things
have been used uh viewed that is as um
indicators or harbingers of change. Um
we talked earlier about um a battle that
took place uh with Alexander the Great
when he defeated the great Persian
Empire and uh the very day that the
battle took place there was an eclipse
and it was viewed by the Greeks or the
Grecians as being a sign that they were
going to be victorious and it was viewed
by the Persians as a sign that they were
going to be defeated. Wow. So this is
like something that we can even look in
history and kind of trace this through.
Yes. And I think we have something to
show regarding that eclipse here. Is
this all coincidence?
Seriously, is this all one big
coincidence?
April 7th is Easter.
Easter is the the pagans. So this total
eclipse that's happening on April 8th
passes through several cities named
Nineveh. Now there's a bunch of other
parts of this as well. One of those
parts is this crazy thing that it
actually happens on April the 8th. You
can't make this stuff up. What does that
indicate to us? It's the sign of Jonah
the prophet. It's the sign of you better
repent. It's a sign of the clock is
ticking. You got 40 days. You got 40
days. 40 days.
Now, McKenzie, here's 40 days. Here's
the thing. You know, we were talking
about the uh the prophecy regarding or I
should say this, the eclipse regarding
the event when Alexander the Great,
here's an image of this when Alexander
the Great uh defeated Darius III and um
the eclipse happened on the day and this
event happened on the day. Wow. Okay. Uh
but as we look at some of the other
events uh the other um signs in the
heavens uh sometimes they happen on the
same day sometimes they happen within
the same year and sometimes they happen
years later. Um so as we look at some of
these other things, we talk about um for
instance uh in the um the the comet that
came in uh 66 AD, the historian Josephus
uh talks about that the comet hung over
the city of Jerusalem like a sword
announcing its impe impending doom. But
of course, Jerusalem wouldn't fall for
another three and a half years. But yet
the uh the comet the the the sighting of
the comet was viewed as a a harbinger of
what was going to happen to Jerusalem.
Ah so by this logic every time there's
an eclipse there's some sort of judgment
taking place. Therefore April 8 was
supposed to be that and Nashville was
going to be destroyed potentially.
Potentially.
Sometimes these things happen on the day
or even years later. They always have to
include the, you know, the potential
escape hatch that, you know, it could be
way off in the future at some point. So,
when nothing happens, well, it did. We
just don't know what yet. Oh, how
convenient, right? They're not setting
dates or anything. They're just saying.
There was an eclipse with Alexander the
Great and the Grecian saw that that was
a sign of judgment. So, therefore,
history even proves that what they're
doing here is biblically sound. Oh,
yeah. And the eclipse is passing through
seven cities that are all named Nineveh.
That also proves this, folks. It
literally did nothing in Nashville
today. It was overcast and rainy.
So when it happened, I was outside and
it literally was just like, well, it's
basically just like Nashville in the
spring.
Oh man. followed by a again a bunch of
clips of a a bunch of other peddlers of
the same sort of newspaper theology that
make a living off of hoping uh on
whatever the current end times, you
know, and whatever proof it is. They put
that guy up there. I can't remember his
name. Him and his wife, they live off
the grid. They have like two million
subscribers. Literally any sort of
newspaper thing, he's always like,
"Folks, it's like, dude, it's not it's
literally it's Easter in the East. happy
uh happy pastoral to our our our friends
in the Eastern church, but that guy's in
the West. Like, it just you see how
silly this is, but it's right in line
with the Adventist Zeitgeist, dripping
with assumptions, bias, inference, just
like almost all of SDA theology is. So,
it's not shocking that it attracts
people like this that apply the same
mindset in this context. There isn't
anything that they've shown or said that
proves anything regarding April 8 being
this hallmark event in history. This is
going to be another drop in the bucket.
No one's going to remember this in five
years. This is about capitalizing on a
certain segment of people, giving them
their fix. And if you went on YouTube
and just typed in April 8, you were
inundated with videos that all had
similar thumbnails of like fire and
explosions and trigger words like war,
destruction, etc.
Don McKenzie, the destruction of
Jerusalem was explicitly foretold by
Jesus Christ. Explicitly, not
implicitly.
There have been thousands of solar
eclipses since Jesus said those words.
This proves nothing about April 8 and
the city of Nashville, Tennessee being
destroyed.
Like not at all. Wow. So if we look at
this specific uh event here with the
battle of Gagamela. So in 331 now the
what I find interesting about it is that
the Bible said that this battle was
going to take place right and that
Alexander the Great was going to be
victorious. So if we go to Daniel 8 3
to8 and we're just going to go briefly
through this but it's so clear. It says
and I'm just going to read the
highlights. There was a ram which had
two horns and then the ram pushing
westward, northward and southward. And
then a hegoat came from the west. The
hegoat had a notable horn between its
eyes. So we have this these two
creatures, two beasts, and ran unto him
in the fury of his power. Smoke the ram,
break his two horns. No power in the ram
to stand before him. So we have this
goat, this hegoat that goes and attacks
this ram. And it's this like symbols,
right? These figures and we need to
somehow understand these symbols, right?
And then in verse 8 it says, "And he the
the hegoat waxed very great. The great
horn was broken and for it came up four
notable ones toward the four winds of
heaven." So we have this picture here of
the heaggo with the one big horn going
at the ram. But the question is how do
we know what this represents? Well the
good news is McKenzie as we go forward
into the scriptures in the same chapter
uh the Bible explains it that uh here
look at what it says here. The ram which
thou solst this is in Daniel 8 20 and
21. The ram which thou sawest having two
horns are the kings of Media and Persia.
And of course here it says in the
highlighted area the rough goat is the
king of Grecia. Well that makes it
pretty simple. It does. I like that. And
so we don't have to guess. Absolutely.
Here we have a prophecy uh and it says
that there's going to be this battle and
that the king of Grecia is going to
defeat the kings of the Mes and the
Persians. And on this day there was an
eclipse.
This is the problem I have personally
with historicism. Sorry historicist
friends who also watch this channel and
are not 7th Adventists. But it is just
too much plugandplay theology. All
esqueological schools folks have their
problems. I don't care what the SDA
church says. They think they're
bulletproof. They think their school of
esquetology has no issues. No problems.
They're, you know, raised up as God's
last day prophetic voice. No. All the
prophetic schools have issues and
problems that have to be worked through.
Historicism is just too much
plug-and-play theology. They all point
to different historical events that they
claim fulfill Bible prophecy, which is
exactly what is happening here. There is
nothing explicit in scripture about the
battle of Gamela in 331 AD.
But because they truly believe that, it
has to be what the text is talking
about. McKenzie even saying it's just so
clear in Daniel 8 followed by reading
nuggets of the text that don't say what
he claims.
Like the text doesn't say that. I always
have to tell Adventists that's your
interpretation.
You guys think you have an infallible
one. You assume that. But the text does
not say what you're saying. That's your
interpretation.
This is coming from the movement that
tells us if it isn't a plain thus sayeth
the Lord, it needs to be rejected. Well,
this isn't a plain thus sayeth the Lord.
It is your extrapolation from the text
with the help of a woman that you think
God was speaking through giving you
infallible interpretive light. But
again, this is being cited to support
the eclipse on April 8 being some
fulfillment of prophecy serving as a
sign in the sky of coming judgment,
cities potentially being destroyed, and
the second coming being around the
corner because
on the day of a battle in the 4th
century, there was an eclipse.
You just referenced um other comets,
stars, and and things like this. So can
you give us some other examples of of
these things? Absolutely. Uh there's a
prophecy in the book of numbers. Numbers
chapter 24 verse 17. And this was a
prophecy given by Balum. And uh we look
the the wise men actually use this
prophecy to find the Messiah. Notice
what it says here in the highlighted.
There shall come a star out of Jacob.
And so um this is why when the star
showed up uh over Judea
at the time of Christ's birth, it had
special interest and of course it was
announcing uh that there was going to be
change and there was change, wasn't
there? There there was a big change.
This was signifying Jesus' arrival,
right? There was. So we have the the
picture here the star over you know
little depiction there and that is
showing again that we have this emphasis
on some of these signs which could lead
us in the direction again we're going to
keep asking this question are these
things significant because we do need we
don't want to be swept away by any wind
of doctrine and we want to make sure
what we're talking about is is founded
on truth. Absolutely. And and and this
is one of the reasons why so many people
are excited about this McKenzie because
they look at these stories in the Bible,
the story of Jesus, the events that
happened. Uh and there's other stories
that happened about these phenomenon
that take place in the heavens. And so
we are to look to these things as being
signs. Yes. So like you mentioned uh we
have this image here. This is from 66 uh
AD when the star or comet or well most
uh most um experts say that this was
actually Haley's comet. Okay. And that
it's it comes in these cycles and it
lines up perfectly with um the the time
there at at Jerusalem when the uh the
original armies of Rome came and then
later came and destroyed it. Wow.
Yes. And the prophecy in numbers was
very specific and foretold of a very
specific event. How does this prove that
April 8 has anything to do with reading
Bible pro regarding Bible prophecy?
This is what's called a nonsequittor. It
does not logically follow that because
there was a prophecy in Numbers that
involved a star, now every event in the
sky is some sort of prophetic
fulfillment or event of scripture.
This is end times grift to try and
generate revenue and clicks by wrapping
it up in all sorts of biblical garb.
Notice the language. This could uh uh uh
this could lead us, it might be, etc.
That's the this leads us. This could be,
it might be par for the course SDA re
reasoning, unfortunately built totally
on theory, speculation, assumption, etc.
But he asked, are these things
significant? We don't want to be carried
away by every wind of doctrine, which is
use uh the the wording of Ephesians
4:14. It's like the irony of this is
Paul was speaking in the context of
unity within the body and that God has
given the church pastors, evangelists,
apostles, etc. to build the body up so
they won't be easily deceived or
distracted by every little thing they
hear, tossing them around with no sure
foundation. Yet, this is exactly what
this newspaper theology does every
single time. People are constantly
tossed around, distracted, misled,
scouring the newspaper to try and find
some secret insight into the future.
What they're talking about is not
founded on truth. It's founded on
speculation and milking an opportunity
to harvest clicks on the new current
thing in the apocalyptic fear pedalling
space. No, the Bible does not tell you
gentlemen to constantly be reading into
solar events that something maybe
possibly could be happening maybe not on
the day but potentially months even
years into the future which is supposed
to tell you Jesus is right around the
corner. No. Get busy for the kingdom
Christian. Live every day to the glory
of God. Start a family. have kids, pass
on the Christian faith, influence your
local community with the gospel, etc.
Too many people, not all, not all, but
many that are into this sort of stuff
are all consumed with this stuff, which
is a total distraction. Yet, they think
it's a noble biblical calling. No, God
is not glorified when you try to use his
word this way. Nothing happens. And the
word of God then becomes a laughingstock
to the world. God is glorified when you
think critically and logically which is
a reflection of his mind something
actually God calls us to do as his image
bearsers reflect him but again the
destruction of Jerusalem was explicitly
foretold don it wasn't an inference or
something like that explicit how does
that now prove that April 8 today was a
biblical fulfillment of prophecy why
April 8 and not any of the other
thousands of solar eclipses prior to
this. Nothing in scripture, folks,
prophesied that on April 8, 2024, the
city of Nashville, or any city for that
matter, in the United States would be
destroyed because a unique solar eclipse
would take place that day. This is an
apples and oranges comparison on their
part. So then we have this great comet
of 1843. The great comet of 1843, it
came out of nowhere. Um, it was a really
bright comet. It was even visible in the
daytime. And the eyewitnesses that saw
it said that the tail of the comet
stretched from one side of the horizon
to the other side. And of course, there
was a great religious revival that was
going on during the 1843 time period.
And uh people believed that Jesus was
coming soon and they looked to this
comment right here as an example that
something of change was coming.
Yes. And the people that looked at that
comment as a sign that Jesus was coming
soon were wrong. Every single one of
those individuals was closer to their
death than the second coming. That's
just a fact. Don said they all saw it as
a sign that change was coming, aka a
super generic sign that anything could
be plugged into. How much change has
happened since 1843 in the world? I
mean, seriously, how does this prove
anything about April 8, 2024? Am I the
only one that fails to see how any of
this has relevance to that? Nashville
wasn't destroyed. Indiana wasn't
destroyed. Illinois wasn't destroyed.
Texas wasn't destroyed. So, we're
supposed to believe it's a ticking time
bomb. And even though it didn't happen
on the day, it's going to start at some
point in the future. Why? What is the
proof of this from scripture? Now,
they're going to jump to Revelation 6.
Pay very close attention. Oh wow. So now
I want to just go to Revelation because
we're seeing all these different
symbols, right, and signs in the
heavens. But I know in Revelation
chapter 6, it specifically talks about
some of these signs that we're supposed
to look for. And we need to identify
if these things have happened, when
they're coming, and and things like
this. So let's go to Revelation 6:12-14.
And it says, "And I beheld, when he had
opened the sixth seal, and lo, there was
a great earthquake, and the sun became
black as sackloth of hair, and the moon
became as blood, and the stars of heaven
fell unto the earth, even as a fig tree
casteth her untimely figs, when she is
shaken of a mighty wind." So, we have
three events spoken of here. And have
these events taken place already,
McKenzie? They have taken place. Now,
they're sort of all lined up together
here, but we will see that the that
between each one of the events, uh,
there's a span of time. And so, it
starts out here with an earthquake. Low,
a great earthquake. Now, it's called the
Lisbon earthquake. Uh, but it
encompassed more than Lisbon. This is of
course Lisbon, Portugal. Uh this
earthquake was uh believed to have been
fulfilled in an area of land mass the
size of 5 million square miles. Wow. So
even by today's it's probably would be
the largest earthquake that humans have
ever seen. Wow. This is and like you
said, this is incredible that we have
these events and in their order
sequentially happening just as
Revelation said they would. That's
correct. So
where does Revelation 6 say anything
about the Lisbon earthquake of 1755?
This is what I mean by plugandplay
theology. They have to find something to
plug in and say this was fulfilled and
we're supposed to just buy that and say,
"Well, by golly, it has." I mean, come
on, man.
But no, had they paid more careful
attention in Luke 21, they would have
seen that Jesus mentioned all of these
things, including the fig tree.
He mentioned earthquakes in Luke 21:11,
the sun, moon, and the stars in Luke
21:25.
and the fig tree that they ignored and
didn't highlight in Luke 21:29-32.
And this is why ignoring the historicity
of Revelation and reading it
anacronistically like the SDA church
does is such a mess. John would have had
Luke 21 and Matthew 24 on his mind when
writing the apocalypse. It parallels
exactly what Jesus foretold that Jesus
would return in judgment on
covenant-breaking Israel, which also
served and functioned as a picture of
the breaking down of the barrier wall
between Jew and Gentiles. Jesus tells us
what the fig tree represented all
throughout his ministry. The cursing of
the fig tree being seen in Matthew
21:18-22
and Mark 11:12-14.
The fig tree often being used as a
symbol of Israel. It was in season, but
the fig tree had no fruit, which is why
Jesus pronounced a judgment on it. This
is who John has in mind as the backdrop
for his primary audience in the
revelation. No, it doesn't mean
revelation has no application to today
because that's typically what SDAs will
jump to. So, you're saying revelation
has no? No, I'm not saying that. I'm not
a hyper predtoist. Hyper predators are
heretics. If you're a hyper predator and
you're here, no, I'm not supporting you.
They like to comment on our videos
sometimes because I have Sam Frost on
periodically, who's a former hyper
predtoist. But no, you're a heretic. But
the parallel imagery found in the
Revelation fit perfectly with Jesus's
own warnings and pictures from his
sermon on the mount and indicate this is
what John has in focus.
Covenant-breaking Israel being judged.
The signs in the sun, moon, and the
stars have to do with the same language
that's found in the Old Testament, which
had to do with the pronouncement of woes
and judgment language on
covenant-breaking Israel. To arbitrarily
poured in an earthquake in Lisbon from
1755 is not sound.
Yet, they will tell us, McKenzie said,
it's just obviously what the text is
talking about because it's the largest
earthquake ever seen. So, that must mean
that's what's in focus in Revelation 6.
What? We have yet to hear how April 8
has anything to do with this. This video
was urgent. That was in the title,
urgent.
Yet, it's just a rehashing of SDA
talking points and claims regarding
fulfilled prophecies.
Now, they're going to get into one of
the infamous SDA dates, which is going
to now be the first domino. Pay very
close attention. So, it started in 1755
and then shortly after in 1780, we had
this incredible dark day. That's right,
McKenzie. It was an unexplainable dark
day. But, as you're going to show in a
few minutes here, uh, that this dark day
was actually preceded by something a
short time before. What was that? So,
that was preceded by a eclipse. An
eclipse. That's right. I think it was 10
days before. Was it 10 days before? And
we have uh several articles here talking
about the different eclipses that were
taking place because then we had the
moon turning to blood as well. That's
correct. And that's what this is talking
about, the partial lunar eclipse. And
that lunar eclipse is what caused this
red blood moon. That's correct. To take
place in 1780. Yeah. There's been lots
of speculation about what caused the
darkness, but it was as dark as midnight
at noon time. And that darkness lasted
for an entire day. And when the and when
that darkness ended, the moon came out
blood red. So just as the prophecy said,
oh brother, it was an unexplainable dark
day even though it literally has been
explained. And it has a lo and it was a
localized event that happened due to
smoke from a forest fire in Canada.
We have an article on this on our
website where you can access all the
source documentation on this. But no,
the sun did not go black on May 19,
1780, fulfilling Bible prophecy of
Revelation 6:12 and Matthew 24:29. These
guys are just pariting SDA folklore.
Now, first notice the August 18, 1874
issue of the Advent Review, where they
state that the sun was supernaturally
darkened on this day.
This is under the heading evidences of
Christ soon coming, which is precisely
what these gentlemen are getting at with
all of this. Quote, "The special signs
of Christ coming in the sun, moon, and
stars have appeared. They occurred
immediately after the tribulation of the
church by her persecutors. And we may
know that Christ is near even at the
doors. And it's easier for heaven and
earth to pass than for the words of
Christ on this point to fail. Matthew
24:35.
The sun was supernaturally darkened May
19, 1780. And the night following, the
moon refused to give her light. And the
night of November 13, 1833 witnessed by
far the greatest display of falling
stars or meteors that has ever visited
our earth. Close quote.
So we see the other date mentioned,
November 13, 1833, which we will look at
momentarily since they mentioned that
one as well. But there you go. There's
the claim that's made by the SDA church.
but ultimately because of course it's
coming from Ellen White and the great
controversy.
On page 308, she writes, quote,
"May 19, 1780 stands in history as the
dark day. Since the time of Moses, no
period of darkness of equal density,
extent, and duration has ever been
recorded." The description of this event
as given by eyewitnesses is but an echo
of the words of the Lord recorded by the
prophet Joel 2500 ye uh yeah 2500 years
previous to their fulfillment. The sun
shall be turned into darkness and the
moon into blood before the great and
terrible day of the Lord come. Joel
2:31.
Close quote.
So May 19, 1780 was supposed to be the
fulfillment of Joel 2, which Peter cites
in Acts 2 as being fulfilled there at
that moment
when the Holy Spirit was poured out at
Pentecost. But the words in great
controversy, Ellen White tells us,
selected messages, book 3, page 122,
paragraph 2, the words in great
controversy are barricaded by a thus
saith the Lord. So what she said has to
for sure be the case. But what actually
happened on New England's dark day as it
is historically known as?
Notice from the International Journal of
Wildland Fire a paper titled Fire Scars
Reveal source of New England's 1780 dark
day. This is from the abstract.
Quote, "Historical evidence suggests
that great wildfires burning in the Lake
States and Canada can affect atmospheric
conditions several hundred miles away.
Several dark or yellow days, as such
events are commonly called, have been
recorded, often with anecdotal or direct
evidence pointing to wildfires as the
source. One such dark day occurred
across New England in 1780, a year in
which people were technologically unable
to confirm the source of such a
phenomenon.
Here we combine written accounts and
fire scar evidence to document wildfire
as the likely source of the infamous
dark day of 1780.
Close quote. Ah, that's right. The sun
didn't go black. It was smoke from a
fire that darkened a small section of
North America while the sun was still
shining just as it ever has.
[Music]
The sun didn't go dark. It was shining
like it always had been everywhere else.
Actually, still there. It was just
blocked. So, Ellen White was wrong. And
no, this wasn't a fulfillment of Bible
prophecy. But there was an eclipse that
happened 10 days before. So, that means
the sun did actually go black. and all
of this somehow supports the idea that
April 8th something radical was going to
happen and Bible prophecy is being
fulfilled. No, they're just paring Ellen
White, which SDAs have been for decades.
Again, go to our website, you can type
in any part of that date in the search
bar and the article will pop up and you
can search to your heart's content and
see all sorts of sources on that. But a
blood moon, folks, is simply another
name for a total lunar eclipse.
It's also sometimes used to refer to
four total lunar eclipses that happen in
the span of two years, which is a
phenomenon that astronomers call a lunar
tetrad. Notice what timeate.com says
regarding this.
This is from an article titled, "What is
a blood moon?"
Quote, "The 2014-15 lunar tetrad
gathered a lot of attention because of
claims by some religious organizations
that the eclipses in the tetrd were a
sign of the end times. Some even called
the eclipses blood moons after a
statement in the book of Joel in the
Hebrew Bible that referred to the sun
turning dark and the moon turning red
before the second coming of Jesus."
Close quote.
Literally, every single time there is a
lunar eclipse, these end times gurus,
prophecy hunters always cite Joel and
Acts 2. Every single time. And then the
world looks at these Yahoos and uses it
to broadbrush Christians as being
crackpot lunatics. And then the
crackpots that do this wear it as some
badge of honor and just dig their heels
in further. Please don't be that way.
Please do not be that way.
Please stop falling for this stuff. This
is not glorifying to God. Start a
family. Have kids. Raise them up to be
laborers for Christ's kingdom. Take the
gospel to your local community. Be the
hands and feet of Jesus. Serve the body
of Christ. Seow seeds for generational
kingdom growth. Sitting around latching
on to every newspaper headline thinking
that you can pinpoint when something's
going to happen is not glorifying God.
Get busy. Get busy. And if you're an
Adventist, leave Adventism. Become a
Christian is step one before any of that
stuff. But Time and Day even has an
entire article on this regarding failed
apocalyptic predictions. Look at this. I
I mean, this is what I'm saying about it
becomes a mockery.
Look at this whole thing dedicated to
this. All the predictions so far in
2024,
death by asteroid,
Nostradamus,
the best doomsday predictions that
fizzle. I mean, they go into all the
Yeah, remember the Mayan calendar,
folks. Am I the only one that remembers
that?
Yeah. Herald camping and the rapture. It
just like Yeah. The black hole from
Geneva. It just uh folks please please
failed prediction after failed
prediction. Please stop falling for
every single time something like this
happens. It's an embarrassment to the
cause of Christ. And every time it's
done in the name of being a watchman on
the wall or whatever. Yeah. Well, if
you're the watchman, we are doomed
because you keep falling for every
single decoy. You're going to fall for
the Trojan horse. Not just that, but you
already have. Now they're going to talk
about November 13, 1833. So these things
have been fulfilled, these ones
specifically that we're talking about.
And there's one more that we're going to
mention that is the falling of the
stars. That's in November of 1833. And
this is written about by presidents. And
you know, this is just so widely known.
And it was like a an American historical
event that everybody knew of. Maybe not
so much now cuz it's a while ago, but uh
Lincoln spoke about this. He wrote about
seeing this event and uh it it was quite
quite something to see. It caused great
religious revival and interest in end
time events because as they had been
reflecting on, you know, first comes
this earthquake, then comes this dark
day, then the moon turns to blood, and
now the falling of the stars. Uh it
seems to indicate that Jesus's coming
would be soon and this is what they
believed.
Yeah. It's so widely known that the
stars didn't fall to the earth and this
didn't fulfill Bible prophecy. Like we
saw in the Advent Review article
previously, this event supposedly
according to them also fulfills
Revelation 6:13 and Matthew 24:29. Now
notice the June 13, 1935 issue of the
same paper and what they claim.
quote, "The stars of heaven fell unto
the earth even as a fig tree casteth her
untimely figs when she is shaken of a
mighty wind." Folks, again, the fig tree
represented Israel.
Revelation 6:13. This prophetic picture
was enacted in the heavens on the night
of November 13, 1833.
The Greek word used here for star is
frequently used in classical Greek as
meteor. The greatest meteoric shower of
which there is any record
took place in 1833
as the numberless meteor struck the
Earth's atmosphere on the night of
November 13. They blazed into a display
of celestial fireworks beyond adequate
description. Close quote. Again, this
isn't stated independently of
confirmation from God through Ellen
White, which is what it which is where
it's actually coming from. It's not what
Revelation and Matthew are actually
pointing to. It's coming from the great
controversy. Notice
quote
in 1833, two years after Miller, talking
about William Miller, began to present
in public the evidences of Christ's soon
coming, the last of the signs appeared
which were promised by the Savior as
tokens of his second advent. Said Jesus,
"The stars shall fall from heaven."
Matthew 24:29. And John in the
revelation declared as he beheld in
vision the scenes that herald the day of
of God, the stars of heaven fell into
the earth even as a fig tree casteth her
untimely figs when she is shaken of a
mighty wind. This prophecy received a
striking and impressive fulfillment in
the great meteoric shower of November
13, 1833.
That was the most extensive and
wonderful display of falling stars which
has ever been recorded.
Close quote. Remember that. Greatest
ever recorded. Yeah, except for one
problem.
No, it isn't. And meteors are not stars,
folks. The term falling star is a slang
term, but stars are not meteors. And
even if they want to appeal to the
Greek, which they did, that the word
aster can mean meteor or meteorite.
Again, Jesus is not talking about
November 13 in the 19th century. This is
just asserted as fact because Ellen
White said it. Well, so that was God
speaking and and that's must be what the
text is saying, right? Meanwhile, again,
Ted tells us, Ted Wilson says, "The only
approved hermeneutic in the SDA church
is the historical grammatical method."
Well, let's see. I I would love to see
it. Let's see the somebody from the SDA
church utilized the HGM and walk us
through the text and let's see how
Jesus's original audience understood him
to be talking about November 13, 1833.
They can't. So, they'll just say, "Well,
it's a double fulfillment." So, that
leaves the door open for them to just
plug and play with whatever they need
to. But notice how NASA defines a
meteor.
A meteor is a meteoroid that comes close
enough to Earth and enters Earth's
atmosphere, then vaporizes and turns
into a meteor, a streak of light in the
sky. Because of their appearance, these
streaks of light are sometimes called
shooting stars, but meteors are not
actually stars. Close quote. Well, like
I said, Adventists are going to stick to
their guns, of course, and assert, well,
that Greek word can mean meteor or
asteroid, not only stars. Well, okay.
Remember what did they say? It was the
greatest event of this ever. Ever. 1833
was the greatest of this ever. Yeah.
Well, it was discovered in 1866.
What caused this event? Which is now
known as the 1833
Leonid meteor shower. And it was the
result of a comet. Two scientists, Erns
Temple and Horus Tuttle, discovered in
that a comet was what caused this event
to take place. With the comet being
nicknamed Comet 55P, Temple Tuttle after
their names. They discovered that this
comet passes the Earth approximately
every 33 years, which means what
happened in 1833 wasn't unique or new.
In fact, here's a documented list of it
passing the Earth all the way back to
902 A, folks. 902 AD. Look at all these.
I mean, they talk about it right here.
The exact image that they were using on
there. Again, go to our website, type in
November 13 in the search bar, and this
article will pop up. You can also see
there's a hyperlink text that says
documented list. Click on that and it
will literally take you through
countless more. This was happening well
before 1833.
Again, how does any of this have to do
with April 8,
but yeah, fellas, not quite the greatest
falling of the stars in history. Once
again, God showed this to Ellen White,
though. She just couldn't get it right.
So, it's God's fault. Apparently,
doesn't matter if you want to argue the
Greek grammar. The Leonid meteor shower
was not an anomaly in 1833. It happened
multiple times prior to then.
He said religious revival broke out
because of this and caused them to
believe Jesus was returning soon. Again,
every single one of those individuals
were closer to their death than the
return of Christ. Doesn't matter that
they genuinely believed this. Lots of
people genuinely believe all sorts of
things.
Doesn't make it true. The Leonid meteor
shower had absolutely nothing to do with
Bible prophecy. And it didn't uniquely
happen one time on that date. Absolutely
none of this has anything to do with
April 8, 2024. This was an opportunity
for them to cash in on all the searches
and hop on the gravy train to try and
then talk about all the standard SDA
folklore and recycle the same claims
over and over and over using this most
recent event as the front for that. If
you're an Adventist or even a Christian
that falls prey to this stuff, I
encourage you, please reconsider falling
every time new things like this pop up.
Utilize your God-given critical thinking
faculties and don't fall for these
grifters. Well, we have all these
examples showing us that we should be
looking for some sort of
heavenly bodily events, you know, signs
that are going to take place. But I know
that if we have these signs, they need
to be coupled with something because we
have the signs in the heavens. But if we
read here in Acts 21:17
and this is talking about the last days
and we believe that we are living in the
last days. Absolutely.
And it says, reading the highlight, "In
the last days, I will pour out my spirit
upon all flesh, and your sons and your
daughters shall prophesy on my servants
and on my handmaidadens, my spirit, and
they shall prophesy, and I will show
wonders in heaven above." So, it's like
connecting these two. It is, McKenzie.
Does it make sense that you would show
signs in the heavens and then not give
some kind of a prophecy to be able to
understand what those signs are all
about? Well, it would make sense that
God gives his message with with the
signs. Absolutely. And so we should be
looking for uh you know we we need to
cut through all the smoke and the fog
about what everybody's saying and you
know saying you know we got 40 days and
all this kind of thing. We really don't
know. But we what we do need to do is we
need to go to the word of God and we
need to see this that uh in the in the
last days that God would work through
giving the gift of prophecy again. Okay.
Well, that that's a very big interesting
topic for sure.
No, none of the examples that they
pointed to prove that the Bible is
telling you to become a theological
astronomer and read into every event
that takes place in the celestial
bodies. Again, thousands of solar
eclipse, folks, just since Jesus said
what he did in Luke 21, they
cherrypicked this current one because
there is a lot of buzz on the internet
and they wanted to cash in on it. So,
don't bring the Bible into this making
Christians look stupid. There's been
zero actual biblical exposition here,
just rattling off standard assertions
and SDA proof texts, not even reading
them in full, but looking at certain
phrases. But of course, like I mentioned
earlier, now they appeal to Acts chapter
2. Yes, McKenzie, Peter said the last
days were already underway. Nothing
about that starting in 1844. Peter was
proclaiming that the prophecy from Joel
was happening right then and there. This
was in a sermon that he was preaching
and he points to Joel when he's
preaching there to Jews amongst many
other Old Testament passages to bolster
that Jesus is the Messiah and that the
Old Testament foretold of him that uh
that's what he was preaching with and
and or that's what he was preaching in
line with and essentially saying what
I'm preaching to you is perfectly in
line with that. Now notice folks,
Hebrews chapter 1, one example, the
author of Hebrews. Long ago, at many
times, and in many ways, God spoke to
our fathers by the prophets. But in
these last days, he has spoken to us by
his son, whom he appointed the heir of
all things through whom also he created
the world.
The author of Hebrews says they were in
the last days. Present tense. In times
past, God spoke through the prophets,
but in these last days, present tense,
God has spoken through Christ,
the one who all the prophets were
forerunners for and pointed to. Nothing
about the last days starting in 1844 and
the gift of prophecy being manifested in
Ellen White. Nor is that what Joel and
Peter in Acts are referring to. Yes, the
sign connected with all of Acts 2
literally happened after Peter's
preaching. Dawn, the Holy Spirit was
poured out on people at Pentecost.
Thousands of people were saved as a
catalyst for growth in the infancy of
the Christian church. They spoke in
tongues. Healings were happening, etc.
Nothing about being a newspaper
detective to try and read all sorts of
stuff into sooner or uh solar and and
lunar eclipses and meteor showers. to
try and now connect this to April 8 is a
horrible, horrible handling of
scripture.
We have uh just as you were saying, Amos
3:7, but he revealed his secrets unto
his servants, the prophets. So, you're
telling me that we should be looking for
signs, but not only signs, but dreams,
people that have dreams and depictions
of these events, too, to correspond to
help us to be able to understand what
these signs are saying because this is
what the prophecy back in Acts uh
chapter 2 says, that he's going to pour
out his flesh uh his spirit on all
flesh. Your sons and your daughters will
prophesy and that there's going to be
signs in the heavens. And so this is all
connected. So then my question would be,
and this is going to be the question we
actually leave on, and we're going to
pick this up in the next episode,
have we seen people having dreams or
visions about these events?
I believe that we have. And if you look
at history, if you look at all the
prophecies, whether it was the coming of
Christ, right, and his star, was that
not prophesied? It definitely was.
Whether it was uh the destruction of
Jerusalem, was that not prophesied? It
was. Whether it was the the defeat of
the Persians by Alexander the Great, was
that not prophesied? Yes. And so we
should then look that there should be
some kind of prophetic evidence to
indicate whether or not this eclipse
that's coming has any uh significance
for us now. Okay. Well, I hope you liked
this first part. We just started getting
into this. We're going to go in a lot
more detail on what people are saying
and how this could connect to us today
if this has real significance. And uh
what are these dreams that Don is
talking about?
Ah, so this whole thing is about
capitalizing on the high search traffic
of this passing event to try and
ultimately plug Ellen White as being a
last day prophet that scripture foretold
of and is needed to help one navigate
through the last days. Remember that
quote that we've looked at uh well a
number of times. It's in the Adventist
belief, fundamental beliefs book. Uh
it's coming from the review in Herald
and Uriah Smith is the one that said it.
Um that in these last days, the Bible
says that there'd be perilous times and
God would send a pilot who would help us
navigate those times. Yeah, that's what
they're trying to segue into here. No.
Amos 3:7 is supposed to support this
somehow. No. More hopscotch exes Jesus,
zero analyzing of context, zero
utilization of the HGM, etc. Amis 3 has
nothing to do with this.
This whole speculation is built on
sinking sand. So remember this the next
time you see more SDA grifting on dates
to try and capitalize on it. Understand
too that no, not all SDAs are like this
and this was an attempt an attempt to
try and say that they are. However,
there is unfortunately a lot of SDAs
that get sucked into this sort of thing.
And people need to understand this is a
grift. This is a grift. This was them
riding the wave. This was the best
performing piece of content that they'd
had in the last month. They did like
four more pieces now after it. There's
like three parts to this one and then
something else that came out. They were
milking this for all it's worth to try
and weasel in all the standard SDA
folklore to try and woo people that are
searching for this to then swindle them
into Adventism because again people that
are into this sort of thing get wooed
and and ahaded. Please folks, please. It
is an embarrassment to the cause of
Christ. It is an embarrassment. It is an
embarrassment. Doesn't mean prophecy
doesn't matter. Doesn't mean the Bible
doesn't talk about prophecy. But no, the
Bible does not command all people to be
these theological astronomers that then
are constantly wrong and then just hop
on the new newspaper headline and then
claim it's something biblical, which
allows these secular organizations and
whatnot to dunk on the church and make a
laughingtock out of the Bible. But as I
stated in the introduction,
this was about showing how weak and
flimsy this sort of thing is. Amazing
discoveries notorious for this.
Walter Ve has been doing this sort of
thing for decades. For decades, he still
sells stuff that he was doing 15 years
ago where you just go back and listen,
it's like, "Wow, that aged like milk.
It's like cottage cheese now."
Nothing comes about. They move along to
the next newspaper headline to string
you along thinking that you're getting
some special insight that no one else
has and the Bible apparently supports
it, yada yada. But no, it's not what's
going on. Thank you for being here and
may Christ richly bless you in the grace
and peace. won by Jesus Christ and his
vicarious death on the cross for
sinners. Marinatha. Amen.
[Music]